okay today I'm going to talk to you
about growth of multicellular organisms
we're going to looking at cell
differentiation cell division and cell
elongation so first of all growth is an
increase in size or mass and we're going
to start off by looking at a process
called cell differentiation
differentiation okay
so before a cell gets a job before it
become specialized it's called a stem
cell so stem cells are unspecialized
then what differentiation means is they
become different they get a particular
specialized job so this stem cell here
that could become for example a neuron
it could also for example become a bit
of cardiac muscle in the heart basically
they can perform any they can become any
different type of cell which allows them
to perform a range of different jobs so
in our bodies we have lots and lots of
different types of cell that's a red
blood cell
that's a ciliated cell so cell
differentiation just means becoming
specialized so getting a specialized job
now this is really important because it
allows organisms to work much more
effectively if there's lots of different
cells that could do lots of different
jobs this differentiation can occur in
plants and animals to learn more about
stem cells please watch the video that
I've made about stem cells okay so
that's cell differentiation becoming
specialized so the second thing we're
going to look at is cell division so
cell division is essentially a process
where we start off with one cell and it
makes an exact genetic copy of itself
and this process can keep on going by
making many more cells the organism will
increase in mass overall so he starts
off for example with one cell there and
it will make two exact copies of itself
then these these daughter cells can also
copy themselves to make more genetic
coffees again so you can see this
process can go on and on to make lots
and lots of copies the process by which
this occurs is called mitosis again I've
got a particular video about mitosis to
show the different stages of that
because it involves just making exact
copies this also occurs in both plants
and animals but most of the growth in
animals normally happens when the
organism is it near the beginning of its
lifetime so in its young kind of younger
phase because when it reaches an adult
there's much less growth which occurs it
stays quite consistent which means this
cell division mostly occurs in order to
repair cells or replace old dead cells
plants however keep on undergoing
mitosis at the roots and the stones
throughout their lifetimes so the final
one we're going to look at is something
called cell elongation now this really
this only happens in plant cells not
animal cells so let's imagine we've got
a plant cell there cell elongation is
essentially when the plant cell can
expand becoming bigger so elongated
becomes longer it becomes bigger and
essentially due to this cell elongation
the plants can increase in mass and
their height so this is yet like I said
it's when the plant cell expands and
this only happens in plants plants only
not animal cells animal stem cells will
always stay the same size we just create
more of them whereas plant cells that
they are able to undergo cell elongation
so just this one on the right that I've
done in green that's the one that only
applies to plants the others apply to
plants
animals so those are the three different
methods by which we can have growth
occur in your multicellular organisms
the only other thing it's worth
mentioning is when this can go wrong and
when this can go wrong we can get cancer
now what cancer is is it's basically
related to this here it's related to
when we have cell division by mitosis
when this cell division happens
uncontrollably we just make more and
more and more and more cells but making
all of those cells we form a tumor now
that's really bad because a tumor can
invade and destroy surrounding tissues
it's really hard to treat as well cancer
because essentially it's just our own
cells so you can't take a drug to kill
these cells because they're your own
cells
you'd kill all of your other cells in
your body too so it's very hard to
target so just to summarize this is
about growth there's three main ways
that we have growth a multicellular
organism self differentiation which
means cells becoming specialized to get
a particular job cell division
which means making exact copies of cells
and cell elongation which only happens
in plants which is where the plant cell
expands and becomes bigger thank you
very much